DENUCLEARIZATION OF THE
PENINSULA THE GOAL FOR THE U.S.
AND YET, OUR TOP STORY TONIGHT
IS BACK IN WASHINGTON WHERE THE
PRESIDENT'S LONGTIME LAWYER AND
FORMER CHIEF PROBLEM SOLVER
EXACERBATED SOME LONG-RUNNING
PROBLEMS FOR HIS FORMER BOSS IN
HIGH-PROFILE TESTIMONY ON
CAPITOL HILL FOR MICHAEL
>> Michael: TOLD MILLIONS
THAT HIS FORMER BOSS IS A RACIS
RACIST, >> Bret: IS A
FRAUDSTER, A CHEAT, AND A CONVIT
FRAUDSTER, A CHEAT, AND A CONVID
FRAUDSTER, A CHEAT, AND A CONVIF
FRAUDSTER, A CHEAT, AND A CONVIL
FRAUDSTER, A CHEAT, AND A CONVIN
FRAUDSTER, A CHEAT, AND A CONVIW
FRAUDSTER, A CHEAT, AND A CONVIO
SHOULD NOT BE TRUSTED.
CHIEF CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE HAS BEEN
FOLLOWING.
GOOD EVENING, CATHERINE.
>> THANK YOU AND GOOD EVENING.
THEY HAD SEVEN HOUR TESTIMONY
INDICATED THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
GREATEST LEGAL JEOPARDY MIGHT BE
IN THE STATE DISTRICT OF
NEW YORK.
HE'S BEEN INSTRUCTED NOT TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT
CONVERSATIONS THAT TOOK PLACE
AFTER AN APRIL 2018 FBI RAID.
>> UNFORTUNATELY, THIS TOPIC IS
SOMETHING THAT'S BEING
INVESTIGATED RIGHT NOW BY THE
SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF NEW YORK.
I'VE BEEN ASKED BY THEM NOT TO
DISCUSS AND NOT TO TALK ABOUT
THESE ISSUES.
>> MICHAEL COHEN, THE
PRESIDENT'S LONG SERVING AND NOW
DISGRACED ATTORNEY WENT BEFORE A
TOP CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEE.
MR. TRUMP'S FORMER FIXER TELLING
LAWMAKERS THAT HE NEEDS TO FIX
ONE MORE THING.
>> I AM HERE UNDER OATH TO
CORRECT THE RECORD TO ENTER THE
COMMITTEE'S QUESTIONS
TRUTHFULLY.
AND TO OFFER THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WHAT I KNOW ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> COHEN NOT MINCING HIS WORDS.
>> I AM ASHAMED BECAUSE I KNOW
WHAT MR. TRUMP IS.
HE IS A RACIST.
HE IS A CON MAN.
AND HE IS A CHEAT.
>> FROM THE ONSET, REPUBLICANS
URGE THEIR COLLINS NOT TO FORGET
COHEN'S TRACK RECORD WITH THE
TRUTH.
>> THE FIRST WITNESS FOR THE
116TH CONGRESS IS A MAN GOING TO
PRISON FOR TWO MONTHS FOR A
LYING TO CONGRESS.
>> TESTIFIED HE WAS GOING TO LIE
ABOUT A TRUMP HOWEVER
REAL ESTATE PROJECT.
HE WAS NOT DIRECTED TO LIE TO
CONGRESS.
>> HE DIDN'T LIE ABOUT
>> HE NEVER EXPECTED TO WIN.
HE ALSO LIED ABOUT IT BECAUSE HE
STOOD TO MAKE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
>> COHEN SAID HE SIGNED CHECKS
ALONG WITH HIS SON DON JR. IN
2017 TO COVER PAYMENTS TO
SILENCE STORMY DANIELS, WHO
CLAIMED AN AFFAIR WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
>> DESIGNED TO BE PAID OVER THE
COURSE OF 12 MONTHS.
>> WAS THERE A RETAINER
AGREEMENT?
>> THERE WAS NO RETAINER
AGREEMENT.
>> COHEN ACKNOWLEDGED
>> MR. ASSANGE CALLED MR. STONE
FOR THERE WOULD BE A MASSIVE
DUMP OF EMAILS THAT WOULD DAMAGE
HILLARY CLINTON'S CAMPAIGN.
>> COHEN CLAIM THAT THE
PRESIDENT WAS GUILTY WITH OTHER
IN THE AGGRESSIONS.
>> YOU'RE A PATHOLOGICAL LIAR.
YOU DO NOT KNOW TRUTH FROM
FALSEHOOD --
BIGGER I'M SORRY.
ARE YOU REFERRING TO THE
PRESIDENT?
>> THIS IS MY TIME.
>> AND I'M GOING TO PRISON.
I'M GOING TO BE AWAY FOR MY WIFE
AND FAMILY.
>> REBUTTAL CLINTON'S
NOT CONVINCED, SUSPECTING THAT
HE HAS A LOT TO GAIN.
>> I'M NOT SURE HOW MY
APPEARANCE HERE TODAY IS
PROVIDING SUBSTANTIAL
INFORMATION THAT THE SOUTHERN
DISTRICT CAN USE.
>> TODAY, REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN
MARK MEADOWS TOOK THE INITIAL
STEP TO MAKE A CRIMINAL REFERRA
REFERRAL, ACKNOWLEDGING COHEN
HAD VIOLATED THE
FOREIGN
ALSO POINTED TO DISCREPANCIES IN
HIS TESTIMONY TODAY.